hi my name is new Dave become myself
that because old dave was a giant drug
addict and alcoholic originally from San
Francisco Bay Area my 20s and till
bronner I when I turned 30 I had been in
bands probably had about two pretty
solid bands up there I come more like
the punk new wave ii scene I was never
like middle guy because I never was good
enough guitar player guy mainly play
rhythm songwriter singer when I moved
down to LA in 1989 read about house in
from a guy named Studio City first thing
I did was called my coke dealer in San
Francisco to male be some coke so that
kind of tells you where my priorities
were at so you know moving through the
80s late 80s Early 90s you know here
comes Nirvana and yes I did witness the
sort of death event crazy Sunset Strip
life you know guys passing out the
flyers in at the other day literally the
sidewalk would just be littered you
couldn't even see the concrete sidewalk
because there's be like Flyers
everywhere so I lived through that era
had a kind of a punk rock band first
then I had a rockin espanol band because
I also speak Spanish I you know what's
cool Spain have worked in Guatemala so
it had pretty good success with that
that band was called Sancho and then my
third and pretty much final Bam and I
have in LA was called Nibiru which is
kind of the name in legends of a 10
planet so it's sort of like a sci-fi
rock and roll band and that was like a
costume band and I had this sparkly
jumpsuit than the handle myself the lead
guitarist was dressed like a general and
our female bass player it was dressed
like a man in black and all the tie and
the suit and the drummer also had some
space suit so we you know i ruined all
these crazy songs you know sci-fi
oriented you know but you know rock and
roll type songs and we have pretty good
act you know you know it's cuz its
costume bands fun to look at we rock
pretty pretty hard and you know we play
all over the place there's a lot more
live music in LA you know just even ten
ten years ago I don't think people
really realize that you know this this
town is really great for live music and
it's kind of a dying art form now so we
mentioned got into the cat club which
was opened up on Sunset Strip I slim jim
phantom of the stray cats is pretty
famous place not as quite as famous as
the Roxy or the whiskey but it did kind
of have that kind of third place you
know like there'd be a lot of Lee you
know crazy band you know people show it
up after you know for for after parties
and you know after they played a mega
concert they come to the cat club you
know plenty of like two in the morning
and yeah so pretty famous little tiny
stage I mean the whole club was you know
maybe twice as big is this ruin and
there's this upstairs or the green room
area so we got in there a couple times
where they actually started like us and
you know we kind of work set to be the
house band I mean you know I could get a
residency where
I could have played it for one night a
week for per month so so we were sort of
had this momentum going so it was good
night you know get pretty drunk and
probably did some kinda really remember
but on the night in question we played
everything's great and I'm good I guess
free drinks from the bartenders at this
point so me and our and the female bass
player you see how pretty cute you know
rock and we're all shaken up so we just
we decide to go upstairs to the green
room cuz no or in the band then we can
shoot it so we get up there and it's
empty and there's a table and there's
like this giant stack of pizzas on the
table like that's kind of weird you know
nobody in there and then we're kind of
mosey in there and there's also a cake
like a big birthday cake we're like you
know we drink and laser stumble over
like look at the cake and says happy
birthday / would like you know the cake
maker get like a Les Paul little bittar
and now it's like wow cool slashes
birthday cake now so we're kind of
standing there wondering what to do and
like you know this after the show was
kind of drunk and we're like [ __ ] it
let's see some pizza because it's you
know it slashes pizza and it's pretty
rock and roll to steal anything
especially slashes birthday pizza so we
both like taking its time you stole a
whole pizza or anything but you know we
just took it you know piece pizza start
eating the pizza after eating the pizza
this guy looked pretty much exactly like
John Turturro the actor
he walks in he goes what [ __ ] you dude
and he walks her and he smacks the peeps
at out of Timmy's hand her since my got
my hands up a guy probably punch to the
face but he took advantage of the girl
so like no sorry no we're just you know
you have like ten pizzas hear anything
he really best to piece of pizza dude
just chill out he got so he was like
really ballistic you know we start to
kind of calm down we're kind of trying
to make a graceful exit and then this
other guy comes in the shaved head like
more like the enforcer type guy like
this guy sort of like I don't know what
his responsibility was but this guy
obviously is sort of like you know he's
schism not some heads together so didn't
break there's no vodka bottles broken
over heads or anything but job but i did
and tammy of course you know she escaped
and just you know she just ran out of
there but i was her like but he blocked
these two dudes and I was kind of drunk
quite frankly I wouldn't mind getting in
a fight but I also didn't want to just
in the night in the hospital so I just
sort of started talking these guys I
said look man hey sorry I'm a big fan
let me just pay for the pizza and they
wouldn't have it you know they really
they were just waiting for me to swim
you know and I wasn't going to swing
first you know if they wanted to swing
first fine you know because I would have
just basically tackled them they're just
put a gun down the staircase anyway but
I started to talk to them and it sort of
became like a cat and mouse game like
this guy obviously you could just you
mean certain people you just know that
they like beating people up
was he you know he this was going to
make it tonight and I wasn't getting
that satisfaction the other guy didn't
really care about he was harmless
basically so it became my sort of i
started to get off on you know trying to
get this guy to not beat me up so i said
look man looking by a beer it's a good
but I get like kung foo my partner's guy
down the stairs and for like the next
half hour I just let him be raping a lot
not berate me but like it was
fascinating to see this guy these two
guys that were so incredibly dedicated
to slash you know like they were so
offended that I have you know broken the
seal on the Holy birthday pizza you know
and it was just it was a fascinating
moment again being pretty drunk at the
time made it even more fascinating and
eventually you know had to get through a
couple rounds of beers of these guys but
eventually I sort of snake my way out of
there didn't really feel safe the whole
night Here I am in my sparkly space
had to sneak back in layer to get my
guitar and stuff because you know what
you finish the set there's not going to
be kind of just cram it over by the
stage it's not like a backstage area
that the cat club so so that's how I
wound up almost getting stopped for
meeting slashes birthday pizza that's
life Sunset Strip and only one of many
stories I'll tell tonight alright thanks